[Musique]
comme c'est fou de marcher ici
j'ai toujours été capable de reconnaître
la
volonté de la chimie et alfonso depuis le tout début
n'était que des camarades de jeu c'est mon frère
carlton il sait que nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre des
vêtements plus grands alors il ne le fait tout simplement pas  grandir
personne ne m'a jamais demandé si je pouvais pirater
cette blague
et vous
ne pouviez avoir aucune aspiration à ajouter Jeff
a refusé l'émission littéralement 10 fois
sera très bon pour me parler des
choses
qu'ils ont dites oh nous voulons que vous auditionniez pour
cette nouvelle sitcom avec un  rappeur j'ai dit que la
soirée pass tape était spéciale c'était juste un
peu comme une soirée du vendredi soir nous prenions chacun
des instruments de percussion c'était une
expérience complète ouais ouais d'accord
nous sommes sur le point de monter sur scène pour le
public là-bas c'était  le billet le plus chaud de la
ville comme ils l'appelaient
james est le cœur du spectacle james
avery était cette bête shakespearienne de six pieds quatre
et je voulais qu'il pense
que j'étais bon comment se fait-il que tu ne me veux pas mec
je tombe dans ses bras au  fin de la
scène et il est hol  me ding et le coup de feu s'est
éteint et il m'a chuchoté à l'oreille maintenant
que je jouais,
je ne savais pas combien de personnes nous
atteignions,
il y aura toujours un morceau de
nous tous dans ce salon notre émission signifiait
l'excellence noire pour les gens l'
excellence  C'était comme ça qu'on
s'aimait je ne pouvais pas fêter 30 ans
de nouveau prince sans toi géant
[Musique]